que s'est-il passé à Nanterre près de
Paris ou un adolescent a priori de 17
ans a été tué par un tir de la police
non le jeune homme n'a pas foncé sur les
policiers comme l'affirme les
professionnels de la récupération
politique à l'extrême droite de cette
émission nous avons sur l'ensemble des
réseaux sociaux une vidéo démente en
catégoriquement cette version on voit
donc sur cette vidéo un véhicule de
couleur jaune les fesses déroulent donc
à Nanterre ce matin aux alentours de 8h
de fonctionnaires de police se trouve
côté gauche du véhicule côté
passager si le refus d'obtempérer est un
délit qui est passible de trois ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
d'amende il n'est pas possible de la
peine de mort quelques secondes plus
tard la Mercedes jaune vient s'encastrer
dans un plot de béton de passagers
prennent la fuite le premier est
rattrapé rapidement le conducteur âgé de
17 ans est touché à la poitrine il est
secouru par le SAMU qui tente un massage
cardiaque en vain bien sûr le reflet
nous intérêts ne peut pas être accepté
mais il n'est pas non plus bien
évidemment capable d'accepter que des
policiers tirent à vous pourtant sur des
jeunes hommes ou des jeunes femmes quel
que soit l'âge d'ailleurs des
conducteurs et vous dire qu'on doit
respecter le deuil des familles mais la
présomption innocence des policiers on
voit un policier qui est sur le côté
gauche du véhicule qui n'est absolument
pas devant le véhicule il est à côté des
roues
donc j'estime au vu de ces images qu'il
n'y avait aucun danger qui se présentait
à ce policier
ce geste m'interpelle me choque mais
encore une fois il y a le ministre la
redit il y a une enquête qui devra
déterminer les conditions dans
lesquelles tout ça s'est produit ne
attention il y a encore un auteur qui
est enfuit moi je ne sais pas quels sont
les gestes
il y avait un conducteur qu'est-ce qu'il
a fait qu'elle a été sa réaction moi je
ne le sais pas je suis sûr que si on
fait le tour ensemble du vieux port on
trouve dix offres d'emploi moi je pense
que c'est la petite phrase facile c'est
la petite phrase facile un président de
la République qui méconnait la réalité
du travail des métiers les difficultés à
chercher un emploi tous les médias
courent derrière cette petite phrase qui
est juste mais pour autant je croyais
qu'il était à Marseille pour le logement
il a réduit les crédits 2 milliards pour
le pays à nouveau là il y a une crise du
logement incroyable dans le pays pack à
Marseille il était à Marseille pour
établir la sécurité il y a jamais autant
de mort dans les quartiers et je suis
pas sûr que ce soit le rôle de l'Elysée
trouver du boulot pour tout le monde
donc après la sécurité le chef de l'État
à bord de cette fois le thème de
l'éducation avec ces images franchement
qui ont deux mois et demi parfois de
vacances
quelques-uns presque 3 mois de vacances
mais on doit concerter ça on va le
travailler pas pour l'année prochaine
c'est un peu juste mais il faut repenser
ce temps dans l'année Emmanuel Macron
souhaite donc ouvrir le débat sur le
temps scolaire avec ses 16 semaines de
vacances la France est au-dessus de la
moyenne européenne vous avez vos mêmes
enfants quand vous les comparez avec des
voisins qui arrivent crever tous les
soirs et qui est venu comment les
Allemands font pour avoir du sport
l'après-midi et parce qu'ils ont un
temps scolaire qui réparti différemment
dans l'année 44% de vie dans cette
emballage de bonbons 54% pour ces
allumettes fumées on monte à 60% de vie
des plus pour ses carrés de chocolat
noir c'est raviolis ou encore ses
noisettes décortiquées le rapporteur
public du Conseil d'État recommandé la
possibilité de participer à des
compétitions de football voilé pour les
jeunes femmes trop de vide dans les
emballages c'est aussi ce que dénonce
deux associations ce matin elles mettent
en demeure cinq grandes marques elle
leur demande de changer leur pratique
d'ici fin juillet sous peine de portée
plainte ceci démontre que nous avons le
droit d'être sur ce terrain-là avec nos
revendications pas nous revendications
excusez-moi mais avec nos appartenances
aux religieuses rencontres insolite au
beau milieu de l'océan capté par un
droniste
je sais qu'il y a une baleine qui est en
train de te suivre elle est vraiment
très proche c'est au fonctionnaire qui
font la France ou plutôt qu'il a défend
qui érige le droit sans aucun mandat du
peuple avec la complicité d'un personnel
politique aux abonnés absents Pierre
Palmade a été aperçue en boîte de nuit à
Bordeaux dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche humoriste est toujours mis en
examen pour Messi des blessures
involontaires dans l'accident de la
route qu'il a causé sous l'emprise de
stupéfiants les médecins ayant estimé
qu'il n'avaient plus besoin d'être
hospitalisé en semaine son contrôle
judiciaire a été allégé cette affaire du
jabs révèle comment le pays est piloté
d'émissions du politique toute puissance
de l'administration soumission aux
minorités actives mec retourne-toi elle
est en dessous de toi elle va t’éflorer
dans très peu de temps
pendant trois kilomètres
l'étonnant du haut va partager côte à
côte le même terrain de jeu ces eaux
turquoises